hello welcome to today's episode today
we're going to show you how to fix the
red ring issue my way
it's actually red ringing yeah yeah I
fixed that no problem it's not because
there's no video cable attached or
anything no who wrote on this as my
brother and his nutty mate for me what
does that say I have to blow that out
yeah a thickness of it as a Brosius yeah
so let's take one each
and on this game as well it's my
favorite game nice Oh
flipping it something pop something flew
out that smoking
where's the game oh yeah it's all right
still in one piece it's still okay good
I'll tell you what I've never actually
played this but if it survives you think
I should play the whole thing
I bet it's actually really good everyone
always raised about there's lego games
yeah I uh I think the disc tray is
broken but the red ring issue is
definitely fixed result yeah yeah yeah
definitely yeah so mainly because the
red LEDs are gone
there wasn't smoke that came at the back
it was just dust that explains a lot
don't breathe this haha i flatly refused
to push the button is it the handle so
wet it's our dog dude you are awful
you're a shocking gonna miss could be
tomorrow by the time you get this
well that's two red rings now sorted
with our X boxes this one sir as you can
see that's not gonna read ring again so
I'm gonna do anything again oh sorry
about your game I slow I'll never get to
play that now dad
I'm sorry dad right I let you got
nowhere to stall off to such a dramatic
quick I've never seen so I tried to
storm out of a field before